and i'm sure that sent the scouts back
to the
scouting reports anthony davis gets a
friendly bounce
gets it to go his first basket of the
night
the defensive styles you're going to see
by coach michael malone and his denver
team there lebron gets blitzed
murray has to check a.d inside the jokic
figure mcgee a lot of dwight howard
tonight
as jokic puts a little english on that
one to score step lebron james off to
the races
murray a little hesitation gets by mcgee
goes to the reverse no but yolk it's
there to clean it up
and that's how joker's just going to
have to get his points eight of the 11
points for the lakers coming
in that pain area how about five assists
for the lakers with five made field
goals as jokic gets all the way in he's
asking for a foul curtis blair and ben
taylor
in the replay center no sap on davis
davis nice finish that's not fair
stunned away game one western conference
finals
name ads go to move 26 teams
and it would have been the same thing oh
nice leaves
and the smart pass right there all you
have to do is raise your eyebrows
make eye contact with your point guard
75 80 percent of the time
they run their offense here's again
jokic jokic
quick rip through of davis gets all the
way to the basket
got kuzma autumn just bullies his way in
spins out of the double team and the put
back by jokic got his own miss
the fact okay now you don't know watch
caruso come i'm going baseline
hit you with this jump hook i missed it
follow my own shot predict but his
upside oh my goodness it looks like he's
going to be around for a long time with
his skill set
and the beautiful step back jumper by
a.d over plumbing you've kind of taken
the joker
out of this game right here he's just
not engaged with these four fouls
a little sidestep by jokic second made
three
james finding davis millsap on him gets
by him davis scores it
a lot of missed free throws for the
lakers as
lebron bullies his way in gives it up
nice find davis hits a three
james you talk about points created
responsible for 40
lakers points at this point 15 points
scored
he set up 25 more and there's jokic
denver needing
rondos six on the shot clock that was
deflected
davis again late clock over yokic oh
he hits it here
miscommunication at the offensive end
and anthony
that's an 11-2 run davis has 24.
jokic gets howard up in the air and the
foul and a chance at a three-point play
patience down low by the joker
two of seven five points we talked about
michael porter junior the third
scorer as anthony davis oh my goodness
rondo's just putting on the show on
denver
boy these two wow they've got something
special you know rondo
davis good find that time on a bounce
pass
well that was special right there and
now rondo forcing that turnover here
goes caruso out of the pack
gives it up rondo bounce pass dave is
patient
and a two-handed jam though davis
good find that time on a bounce pass
back spasms missed the entire round one
against portland now he goes strong
again
misses dave is trying to keep it alive
and comes away from the pack with it
taking on three nuggets
and a little turnaround jump hook is
good
rondo there's another bounce pass to
davis and he'll finish
good catch by davis that's the second
overhead bounce pass that rondo has
delivered in this game
davis he's got jeremy grant on him he'll
just pull it knock it down
37 for anthony davis so easy